this is ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsay personality best-selling
author
and host of an explodingly popular
podcast i got to come up with a better
phrase than that but
but it is healthy explodingly is
explodingly popular
it's uh it's it's yeah there's a lot
well anyway but dave you've been there
for 30 years there's a lot of people
listening to it in a very short period
of time
and i i'm proud of it and i
uh i'm proud of you and i love that it's
popular because what you're putting out
there
the material the answers to questions in
people's lives is
absolutely valuable and it is uh it's
unique
and it's fresh and refreshing and so i'm
glad that
i'm glad the curve on the listenership
is through the roof
i appreciate that plus i just like being
associated with a big hit well and
i think 30 years you've been making up
words so why start now stop now right
we're going to go with exploding this
isn't the season to fix your grammar
dave so i say
explodingly let's do it man i'm in it's
uh it's a little late in life
because um number one i'm beyond help
number two i just really don't care
that's that's the the traffic the
dufecta
that one does it right there so open
phones if you want to talk to this
couple of clowns open triple eight eight
two five
five two two five we'll talk about your
life and
your money uh the call is free and some
say the advice is worth exactly what you
pay for it
laura is with us in los angeles hey
laura welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up um i'm a little nervous i'm
going to try to calm down
you'll be fine we've never lost a
patient you'll make it okay
my husband and i are at um total odds
kind of right now what to do about
a decision and so um we're calling you
so we're new listeners we've only been
listening for a couple months but we've
listened a lot
and so basically we're 50 and 60 years
old
all of our money is in uh real estate
we've done well in real estate we have
about six thousand six million dollars
in a
paid off real estate it's all rentals i
hate it when that happens
and we probably made some stupid
decisions but we were lucky and it
worked out
i think you've made some good decisions
somewhere
okay so anyway where we're at right now
is
everything is owned outright except for
our personal residence
and a vacation home in palm springs
that's very successful airbnb
um our personal residence is worth like
1.6 million and we owe
350 000 on it and on a rental home is
worth about a million
and we also owe 350 000 on it my husband
wants us to sell
a paid off rental that's about
worth about 350 000. they'll be on free
and clear it brings in about two
thousand dollars a month
and it's really it's a condo it's easy
you know
it's just the money just comes in he
wants to sell that
to pay off our palm springs airbnb
just so he just feels like he's 60. now
he just wants to not have that debt you
know he wants to just have a home
mortgage then he wants to really attack
the home mortgage
this whole debt free idea is brand new
to us you know so
um and i want to keep it because we have
no
retirement other than renters we have no
stocks we have no i have 6 million in
real estate
we
no whining allowed this condo is not
going to break your retirement bank
right sorry uh i mean it's okay
why so why did he pick that condo to
sell out of all the other properties
um he wants to sell something and i
think he well also the
our tenant just moved out so vacant
which california rent laws would make it
easier
you know to sell a vacant unit and so
it's just sitting there and rented you
know it's just
and we're at a stalemate like kind of
locking the heads and i said well why
don't we take
rent it take the 2000 and since we don't
need that to live on it just
attack the palm springs mortgage you
know and then we could just
and if they're already on 15-year fix
that we're already
only 13 years old what is your household
income it's all off of rental properties
is your income
all off of rental basically yeah so what
did you take in in cash that you put in
your pocket that you paid taxes on last
year
200 000 on six million
well yeah well it was like 340 is what
it
brings in but then we have we write off
a lot yeah
i'm talking about not i'm not talking
about uh depreciation
but i mean you have actual expenses that
eat your cash
i would hope you're making 340 after
expenses on six million dollar portfolio
uh well maybe it's just because real
estate's so expensive like our home is
in that you know what i mean
you should have 340 000 income
net of expenses before depreciation
on six million dollar portfolio anyway
that's still low but
you ought to at least have that yeah
so what is the cash after expenses
before depreciation
that you guys have coming in to work
with
um i'm not sure okay
well that'd be a good number to have
okay because that's called your income
right that's what you have to work with
because if i wanted to answer the
question
how fast can i pay off 700 000 worth of
real estate
debt i would need to know what my income
is
to do that with i will tell you 24 000
on a property that's worth 350 000 as
your
gross income meaning you're netting
somewhere around 17
000 really sucks the roi on that condo
is
pretty full yeah it's bad
i don't care if it's low if it's not got
much hassle
you're not you know you're not making a
you're making what four percent on your
money
mm-hmm that sucks so i
thought i was hoping maybe you're gonna
tell me he picked it out because the
income's horrible on it
but um i know it's just that it's empty
yeah right now okay
yeah well i i'm as you know from
listening for just a few weeks i'm going
to lead you to be debt-free as fast as i
can so the answer to your question
is going to be you have to go back and
do some homework and you guys have to
keep talking
because you need to get to the bottom of
this so number one we need these
properties
to be producing and a cash on cash
rate of return that is substantial
okay number two once that's our income
once we know what our income is number
two
how fast if we keep the condo can we get
these 750 000 worth of debt cleared
how many years is that going to take how
many years is that going to take five
years six years seven years he's 60
years old
he doesn't want to leave you with that
mm-hmm
and that's that's the goal okay he's
trying to take care of you
so uh then then uh if you if it's going
to take you
15 years because you're really making
200 000 on this 6 million because your
your real estate sucks um if that's
really all you're making on it
and it's going to take you 10 or 15
years to clear this yeah you need to
sell the condo
because you need to clear this debt as a
part of preparing
for him to not be there or if the golden
years whatever we want to call these
these next this next decade or two if
you're if however you're making three or
four hundred thousand dollars that you
have cash on
at your fingertips which i suspect you
should be i mean unless these properties
are just not well run
uh you should be well yeah okay i feel
like because
everything's so expensive it's not
anything to do with it
right okay if a property is worth
a million dollars it should rent for a
price
the rental price should reflect the
value of the property
right if you've raised the prices as the
values have gone up
because rents go up as values go up and
so
anyway i own several hundred thousand
dollars several hundred
million dollars of real estate i love
real estate so
it's my you're my sandbox right now
kiddo so you either need to clear the
debt with your income
or you need to clear the debt by selling
the condo in the next five years
now you run the numbers out and decide
which one's the best hey folks i got a
great option to help you pay for your
education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
well speaking of real estate if you've
ever made a dumb decision with zeros on
the end you know you didn't do your
research
me too most people make choices based on
feelings or opinions especially when
buying a house
but when it comes to the real estate
market feelings aren't your friend
facts are well john says that about a
lot of things
so check your facts find out what you
can actually afford
research what's trending in home prices
talk to a
reputable real estate agent in your area
never buy a house again without fax
text the word house to 33
789 to get an agent who will help you
make smart decisions
text house three
seven eight nine sarah is
with us in dallas texas hi sarah welcome
to the ramsey show
hello thank you so much for having me
sure how can i
all right well um my husband and i are
in baby step two and uh since december
of 2019 we've paid off fifty eight
thousand dollars
all right and we only have about three
here we're very proud of that but
we are on the second half of our debt
now and that's 37 000 left
in student loans but due to increased
costs of having a second child over last
year
and taking a job of a decreased salary
our shovel is substantially smaller
compared to what it used to be
so i'm trying to think of ways
brainstorm ways to be gazelle intense
given a new situation
and i had this crazy idea and my husband
was not super thrilled with it and
actually asked me if i could call you to
talk about it
what if we paid off our paid or what if
we sold our paid off cars
um if we did that it would be a big step
but it would wipe out this 37k
immediately and we could then focus on
all of the other things that we need to
do and then you have a forty thousand
dollars
back into a car we have two twenty three
thousand dollar cars
oh you'd sell both your cars yes that's
why it's a big step
what would you and then you get your two
beaters huh
yes maybe not beaters and what is your
house what is your household income
140 000 a year
and why can you not pay off 37 making
140 000
um so we bring home 8 800 a month which
is a lot and we're very fortunate
um 5 000 of it goes between daycare and
our mortgage they're about the same
that's over five thousand dollars
uh we spent a thousand on groceries
diapers household things
your day care is 60 000 a year
uh yeah but well between the two kids uh
we pay
2 200 a month so not 50 000 a year
that's that's not five thousand oh five
mortgage plans
i'm sorry it's between day care and
mortgage oh yeah
okay 104 140
i don't know why mortgage and daycare
are on the same list but anyway we'll
put them there
so 140 minus 60 isn't that isn't that
80.
140 minus 60 is 80. yeah why can you not
pay off 37
000 again so i can pay off thirty seven
thousand dollars i have a thousand
based on our no our debt snowball i have
a thousand dollars a month going towards
that
i don't think your budget is very
sacrificial
and that's true there are other things
that we could we could yeah like you're
still doing a whole bunch of crap
that you don't need to be doing okay
well then we'll take a look at that and
make it a little bit i mean
help me with this because i'm not just
making this up i mean i just took 140
and i took out the mortgage and i took
out the daycare which were your two
primary things you're worried about you
don't have any payments except
except a student loan payment and we
took care of daycare and we took care of
the mortgage now we got to buy lights
water and food
and you can't find 37 thousand dollars
that's just weird um okay well looking
looking at our budget and the growth
that we come home with like i said it's
8800
yeah that's 120 000. that's 120
absolutely
minus well and that's our growth right
that's what we take home after taxes or
our net i'm sorry now i know
and then we take uh and then it's about
a thousand dollars on food
diapers other household items that's 12.
um a thousand on student loans
about seven hundred dollars in bills and
at the end of the month we may have an
extra five hundred dollars left which
will go towards
um towards our species you did not get
down to five hundred dollars
your budgets you're still not doing it
i'm sorry i'm the only thing i'm good at
is math
and you still did not spend all that
money so you've got some work to do
kiddo
sharpen z pencil sharpen the pencil
uh so one car maybe but i don't think so
you're putting a thousand dollars a
month towards
37 that's 12 of the 37 so all you need
is 24 000
all you got to do is find 24 000 out of
140 120 take home pay
for one year and to do it in one year
then if you want to do it in two years
all you need is twelve thousand dollars
i'll do it in one year just get it done
with it i i
really think you can do it i really
think that there's some i i think
there's some whining in this budget i
really do
yeah it does it sounds like i want to be
comfortable
let me tell you i'll go further i don't
think you're doing the whole budget
because you're you're doing this from
your head
that's why you've got daycare and
diapers broken out of separate line
items
they're you know diapers don't go in a
separate line item they're not that big
a line item
you're you're trying to crack crank this
through in your brain you need to sit
down and do a
written detailed line-by-line budget
with every dollar
every dot get on the every dollar app
with your husband the two of you give
every dollar
a name and you're gonna see where why
i'm why i'm raising up on you
you're going to see there's money left
here and you can knock this out no you
don't need to sell your cars you need to
tighten your budget and lower your
stinking lifestyle
and i actually think that when she first
called dave i was going to say yes sell
your cars and be done with this thing
but i think
i think the exercise oh it's right it's
much better than selling the cars yeah
this is going to be a uh i hate to use
this working a spiritual exercise for
this crew to get down and
and see what you're made of yeah yeah
this is going to force you to do the
last 10
of truth yes which is the hardest is the
detailed budget
because you can i mean you could do big
piece budgets in your head
and when you make 140 grand you just
feel like you got so much wiggle room
right and you should have and it's
frustrating when you get to the end of
the month and there's no money
money left but you haven't detailed it
out i'm
i might be wrong but i'm not i'm not be
wrong but i'm not
been doing this too long so that's my
opinion you keep digging on it kiddo if
we can help you we're here to help you
but part of the time we help you by um
by raising up because we love you we
want you to win
all right up next is going to be armin
armin's in los angeles hey armin how are
you
good how are you guys better than i
deserve what's up
all right so before i get into my
question i just want to give some
context on my situation right now so
i'm 17 years old i'm on my last semester
at a
community college and i'm about to
transfer to a uc school
but i'm faced with two different um
conflicting opinions so
i'm faced with the dilemma where if i
transfer to uc irvine
i would need to rent out a private house
through uc irvine housing
and on the other hand if i go to ucla
i'll need to
get a car um but it's that question of
should i lease or should i buy
because my surroundings of family and
friends are
they're they're both raising pretty good
arguments for leasing and buying so
i don't know what a car
oh okay well the only people that
promote leasing a car are broke people
okay i mean the wealthy people don't
lose cars
i mean a few of them do but but by and
large let me tell you we did a study of
10
000 millionaires the largest study of
millionaires ever done
none of them not a single one of the ten
thousand said
you know i became a millionaire because
i i really leveraged
the use of that car by borrowing on it
yeah not one i mean it wasn't a small
percentage
it was freaking zero armin now this is
not your broke friend or family member
who can make an intellectual argument
this is real millionaires they don't
borrow money on cars dude
and when you ask them what the largest
mistake they ever made in their working
lifetime they usually say
i borrowed to buy brand new cars i
bought a new car i bought a brand new
car when i was 26 and i was so stupid
when i was 26
and now i'm 46 and i'm i would have been
a millionaire four years sooner if i
hadn't bought that stupid buck car
on payments that i couldn't afford to
buy so to answer your question norman i
drove a 1988 twitter turcel easy
hatchback it cost a thousand bucks i
bought it from some lady at my church
whose husband had passed away
and that got me through my undergraduate
it got me through my first year of my
professional job
and that's still driving somewhere right
yep buy
the cheapest beater car you can get to
get to and from you're a
18 year old kid don't take financial
advice from broke people son
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sean and char are in denver and it says
on my screen
that you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you how much have you paid off
we paid off a hundred thousand dollars
in
27 months wow good for you and your
range of income during that time
it's actually pretty steady we are about
a hundred thousand dollars a year
okay so kind of like the lady i was
talking to a minute ago making 140 to
pay off 37 they paid off 127 months
making 100.
exactly so i have to hear the story now
because it seems like maybe i know what
i'm doing okay
so allegedly what kind of debt was the
100
000 our debt was the irs
heloc like credit cards auto and medical
bill
wow i mean you had so you had some nasty
piranha in that pond
yes yeah the tax man was uh not real
happy with us
yeah how much of the 100k was was was
the kgb i mean the irs
it was about 20 000 with the irs how did
you end up owing that much in taxes
uh well i went a few years without
uh filing
[Laughter]
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna go with a my
bad on that one yeah
i'm just thinking that yeah i got it
oops
yeah so uh what happened 27 months ago
what was your wake-up call two and a
half years ago
uh well so sharon and i have both
been through one marriage already so
when we met
we decided that we were gonna base our
relationship
in uh god's word and uh try and live
our relationship by his will and uh
as as we were moving through and we
decided to get married and
we were planning our wedding we were
kind of noticing how much it was going
to cost us
and uh you know as part of being
living in god's will was to be good
stewards of his blessings
so you know and being one of the
blessings that he's given us
is you know our financial uh money and
how much we make and you know so we're
we were talking about it and
decided that you know we wanted to cash
roll our
our wedding and we wanted to get out of
debt and
you know start our our life together on
on the right foot
so that's kind of how we decided to do
that and
i'd heard of uh you from years ago
you're kind of a household name around
our
our family and um so we got your book
and we were reading it to each other uh
before bed for about a week or so how
romantic right
yeah right well i gotta admit i put char
to sleep a couple times
that would be me you were reading it but
i would be the one but
that's great i love it so a hundred
thousand dollar income what do you guys
do for a living
um i um own my own hair salon
business in boulder colorado yeah
and i am i i design medical equipment
very good
okay so you've been married about uh two
and a half years three years
uh coming up on two years in may okay so
you started the process a little bit
before marriage then
yes okay excellent excellent well
congratulations you guys
who had the first conversation with who
who actually sat down and said
hey what if we did this because that
first conversation especially for a new
couple
takes a lot of courage a lot of
vulnerability who who's the first one to
have that conversation
that totally is on sean's shoulders
so he looked at his wife and his
soon-to-be wife and said what if we just
scaled back and cash flowed this and
what if we stopped spending so much
money and you were all in
all in yeah oh that's cool yeah
so you were feeling the stress in the
pinch too then
well yeah we i mean i came into our
um relationship with
you know a good sixty thousand dollars
of that hundred thousand dollars
that we had and i just didn't you know
when you
have that much debt you don't i don't
know like i didn't know where i was
going and i was living paycheck to
paycheck and i didn't want to be like
that that was
my typical my family's typical
and that's i didn't want to do that i
wanted to change that
you just think that walking through life
with those ankle weights on and
not sleeping and not knowing how we're
going to eat the last couple days that's
just normal right
yeah get used to it yeah yeah how's it
feel now that you're out
oh my gosh it's amazing uh and honestly
i
as soon as we started doing this and we
were knocking bills out left and right
that's when my
i started to feel like i was free
it is great you don't even have to be
there you just got to know that you can
get there
yeah yeah we saw it coming it was great
so what did you learn about yourself and
about each other through this 27 months
well we were we were just talking about
that this morning and
um you know one of the things that we
learned was
you know we we don't always speak the
same language when we're talking about
our finances and budget and you know
just life in general so
sitting down and forcing ourselves to
learn how the each other communicates
and you know how to
how to listen and speak each other's
language was
really nice and so give me an example of
when one of you was speaking french and
the other one speaking russian
um you know it usually came up when we
were doing our budget
and char would be trying to make sense
of the
numbers in in her head and i'm trying to
make sense of the numbers in my head and
you know i'm looking at it as you know
an engineer and she's looking at it as a
hair stylist so
those two things didn't always uh line
up okay so the nerd and the free spirit
for one thing right
yeah yeah or the spreadsheet
lover in the room the guy the guy
reading
a financial book to his his new wife in
bed
and the artist right and i'm falling
asleep
that's right yeah i am the artist right
yeah yeah this is great i love it guys
you guys are amazing i'm so proud of you
very very well done what do you tell
people the key to getting out of that is
um well i think that the key or
our secret anyways is that it has to be
you have to get over the heart problem
instead of it having a math problem
so when you change your heart the math
will do itself
oh yeah profound very well done
good good job you guys well we've got a
copy of rachel cruz's latest
new york times bestseller know yourself
know your money and it'll help with the
russian and the french yes that's what
it's for what would you tell to a new
couple
who's about to get married or just got
married that
how this benefited you too because i
want you to give hope to folks who are
thinking
i'm not gonna have this conversation
definitely a hard conversation but
i think in the long run i mean it's
definitely well worth it i mean it's
just to have
the debt off of your shoulders and not
have to worry
about anything like when also the when
the pandemic hit
because of my career you know we were
closed for two months out here and we
didn't have to
it didn't hurt us as bad as most people
would because we were on a budget
and um we still live on a budget
even though we're debt free yeah me too
i
i just i tell everybody that they should
do it whether you're married or you're
single because
just the financial freedom and that
weight lifted off of your shoulders
is huge i can't even explain it like
and i i'll even go once i'll go one step
deeper and suggest that
you all two have worked together on a
hard thing they got behind
the thing right you got behind the the
fear
and you guys worked through something
hard together and now you all know hand
in hand y'all can conquer anything
it's not a matter of if but when life
throws its next thing at you y'all two
both know we can do this because we've
done it
we're going to take over the world next
there you go man i love it man well
it needs a good taking over so would you
please get in business
hurry up sean hey pay your taxes on the
way too brother keep your taxes paid
that way the world won't kick back but
yeah i love it congratulations all right
sean and char in denver colorado 100 000
paid off as newlyweds in 27 months
making 100 grand count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
now let's just round that 27 months up
to 36 months and call a hundred thousand
33 000 a year making a hundred thousand
and i will say it for you america dave
was right
he's always right it's frustrating i sit
next to him and he signs my paychecks
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today julie is in denver
hey julie welcome to the ramsey show how
can we help hi thank you for taking my
call
sure what's up um i have kind of a funny
situation
i have a brother-in-law who just offered
to take us
on a trip uh this summer
we're on baby step two and this year
already has
we've had some extra bills come up with
some medical
stuff we think it's strange that they've
offered to pay for a trip for us
and we don't know how to say no we don't
want to go because we don't ever want to
pay them
back even though it's a gift why is it
strange
well they have not talked to us for
about six years
and then in the back excuse me about a
year ago
they've had a change of heart and want
to reconnect
that's nice yeah it's nice it's nice
it's your your husband's brother brother
yes
so is there something about this gift
you feel like is going to have strings
attached to it
yes there my husband
and his brother had a fight over a
four-wheeler
um about six years ago and it's just now
being repaired
whoa the fight is being repaired before
the relationship the relationship like
we're being invited back to family
gatherings
and stuff oh so you got ruled out a mom
and dad's and everybody's
yes you know that was bigger than a
four-wheeler right
i think so yeah
bigger than a four-wheeler yeah that's
probably some 30-year-old stuff that
was proxy ward with the four-wheeler i
think so it was a joint owned
you know father and sons four-wheeler
yeah
and it got ugly or you don't ever
communicate family members over
a toy right there's usually other stuff
there uh yeah there's big stuff
but it's strange you know just the other
day they offered to
bring us on this trip and we're on baby
step two and we are just not there
to go on vacation but it's strange we
don't know how to answer because if we
say no it's a money thing and then they
say
we're paying for it how much of this is
um
your pride i don't
know well it would be kind of hard to be
like thanks for the airfare
and hotel and why is that hard
i just don't want it to blow up down the
line and be like well we took you here
i don't know i don't i didn't think
about that dr john
actually so there's probably i i gotta
i'm gonna defend her a minute okay
i'm i don't think it's pride i think
she's
uh gun shy it feels like you're you're
projecting a future
you're well i mean a future these people
will blow you up over a four-wheeler why
wouldn't they blow you up over
yeah come back later and circle around
hit you in the back of the head over a
paid-for trip that's right
yeah but i also if somebody says man
what an
idiot brother i was for losing out on
six years of relationship
hey i want to start spending some
intentional time together
and then all of a sudden i walk up and
y'all are in baby step two of this weird
cult
that's happening off in nashville and
it's like hey cool come with us
we're gonna so i in the only reason i'm
asking i'm trying to be provocative with
you
how much of this is you saying i'm too
fancy
i'm too i've got too much pride to take
someone else's money
versus no man if we do this this is
going to end poorly for us
because i think to answer your question
i think it's relatively easy
you say hey you know what we're not
going to do vacations this year we're
going to stay in
if y'all want to come visit us that'd be
awesome but we're not going to vacations
this year
next year the year after we can't wait
and then your boundaries are your
boundaries and if they want to throw a
temper tantrum over that then you've got
your question answered for you right
okay you knew they're using this as
something else otherwise if they say
great we can't wait so we can do this
again
just so you know money's never a thing
with us but we're coming
we want you with us and we're going to
make up for lost time then you know hey
there's something bigger at play here
right but trust your gut right
i guess i don't have a i don't have a
problem either way with it yeah
john's point yeah that uh are hovering
around in his point i
i think is um if this is truly an
olive branch don't saw it off that's
what i'm
feeling and that's why i don't know how
to well no i'm saying there's a way to
uh to you know push it to the side
gently but you don't have to saw it off
and so number one you don't need to
respond your husband does this is about
him
right and he responds and says hey bro
man
i really do want to reconnect and this
is this means a lot to me that you would
offer to pay for this and it's so kind
and generous of you
we are committed to this plan and i know
that might not be something you
understand but
um we're going to stay home but it's not
because of anything except we're working
this stuff
and i know you're paying for everything
but it's just it doesn't work for us
this year if y'all want to come down
hang out get your hotel in the area
you know we'll go to dinner we'll all go
out and throw frisbees in the backyard
we'll do some stuff like that
and then maybe another year we'll go on
vacation together but i just can't do it
this year and thank you so much for
reaching out and if
if he then bows up and goes well you
won't take my gift and run around
then you go well see there it was okay
like john said
but it's it's a way to test the waters
without smacking
the possible reconciliation in the face
or without ending up four days into a
seven-day cruise reeling like
oh no what did we do no we can't get
away
yeah we're stuck on a boat now i'm stuck
in here with cousin eddie
yes yeah okay that's fair
that's fair yeah and and my husband will
talk to him i won't
respond for him uh i just we talked
about it the other day and we're like
we don't know how to say this yeah
well it's it's it's it you know it
it is way over there on the edge of
awkward
yeah but hey julie i also i also want to
put this out in the water
it is easy from you and your husband's
perspective to look at your brother
in law and say man i can't believe he
burned us for six years over a
four-wheeler
but your husband's got to own some of
that too it wasn't a four-wheeler
there's something else going on there
he may not have the tools to have this
conversation well so he's gonna know i
gotta be gentle i gotta be
appreciative i wanna i wanna always go
into this thing assuming it's an olive
branch
i love that analogy dave i'm not gonna
cut it i'm not gonna sell it off i'm
just gonna move it aside
and say not this year but soon but soon
yeah gently
yeah yeah but and then that's having you
having strength and
boundaries and you and it also gives you
a little bit of a
a little test here because i'd rather do
frisbees in the backyard than in cancun
for a week
yep you know in this weirdness so let's
just have a little
where there's a little better escape
hatch and everybody's not heavily it's
heavily committed and
you know you you that kind of stuff so
uh yeah
i would want we want you to rebuild the
relationship if it's possible
absolutely and it doesn't have to start
on a paid for vacation in spite of your
hurt and in spite of your scars
yep yeah john is in tampa florida hey
john
welcome to the ramsey show how can we
help
thank you dave and john for taking my
call my wife and i
are in baby step seven uh we have paid
for
rental property that i'm trying to
figure out what our roi
is on that to determine whether they are
a good investment to keep long term we
don't we've owned it for about 10 years
is it a residential house
uh it's short-term rental actually so
they're vacation rentals
okay um well usually those have much
higher management fees
management company takes a big bigger
chunk right
yeah we actually manage it ourselves
okay um and you so
you're like running a vrbo type thing
correct okay yeah the benefit is is that
you get high rents when you get them but
then there's the off
correct and we've had a significant
increase in property values over the
time too which has been beneficial but a
significant increase in
turnover of the tenants i mean it's week
by week it's not
yeah okay correct it's a pain in the
butt i'm just trying
okay on residential traditional
residential
uh i i own a bunch of houses and our
portfolio averages a little north of
eight percent
cash on cash
okay meaning that the value of the
property
it we generate eight percent of the
value after expenses
without depreciation not counting
depreciation not counting
increase in value cash on cash
also the actual cash you paid for it no
the actual cash oh value of the property
it
it's uh it would be cash on cash if it's
cash you're correct but
we do it on value we want to see our
rents coming up to match the values to
keep us
around that eight percent mark after
expenses now that's a traditional rental
house that rents for a year
not by the week by the week you should
be making more
because you got a lot more labor and you
got to account for the gap
of no rent and you got those you know
you got these gaping holes of off season
and all that kind of stuff
so yeah you you know if you're not
getting north of that you should
probably rent it straight up instead of
vacation rentage
because you got to paint you're dealing
with a pain in the butt this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where dad is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the
ever-popular dr john daloni podcast is
my co-host today as we talk about your
life
and your money it's a free call and some
say the advice is worth what you pay for
it triple eight
eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five
two two five mike is with us
in columbia missouri to start this hour
hey mike what's up
hey dave first off i want to say um
listen to your show for a while and it's
changed my life
so thank you for that thank you i'm
honored
yeah kind of facing a decision now i'm
kind of looking to make a change in my
career and i'm looking at
two jobs both of them are paying a
little better than i'm making now
but the one kind of on the lower side
it has a better location
[Music]
i i can't it has just a lot of
intangibles that are great about the job
as far as a good boss
be a part owner in the company um
but on the other hand i have another
high paying job that
the location is kind of up in the air
it's a bigger company and there's
probably more room for advancement
i just wanted to see kind of what you
thought about that as far as
what does each one pay the lower paying
job
pays about eighty 000 and the higher
paying job
i could probably within two or three
years probably make double that
okay um doing what in each case
um they're sort of in the sales industry
so you're so you're a sales guy
yeah sales and consultants yeah okay
so the intangibles must be pretty
stinking high for you to be willing to
take half pay
yeah um like you said it's kind of my
dream location
the the boss is a really successful guy
and
i think yeah but you're not gonna be
i don't really care about his success
i'm worried about yours
yeah unless you're 23 and you're going
to put in two years and learn from
an extraordinary mentor is going to
carry along the way and you're going to
have somewhere to go
yeah how old are you yeah i'm 24.
okay all right so is that your idea
you're thinking you can
kind of write you can learn from this
guy because he's a he's a butt kicker
um i think that's part of it and then
yeah the location is
i want to live there it might be more
exciting
there's something else here what's the
what's the the thing you're not saying
are you looking for permission to not
take this job that you don't really want
it's going to pay a lot um
i don't know i guess what's the location
what's the location of the of the
underpaid one that's so
that's so appealing um it's
so i would be in training um kind of
around the columbia area
and then it's up in the air where i
would go it's been thrown out georgia
um that's the eighty thousand different
locations no that's the higher page
okay what about the one that's got the
great location where's the great
location in columbia
it's no it's in the pacific northwest
black wire like seattle area
okay so you want to move to seattle
uh that's appealing to that area that's
appealing to you
yes why
i like the outdoors and you know it's
nice to be able to
kind of go in your backyard and it's all
there and go fishing after work and
different things
which i know you can do in georgia
that's just not the same
it sounds like you're putting a lot of
pressure on yourself to make a forever
decision you're 24 years old man
and if you were telling me that hey i've
got the opportunity to work
for dave ramsey for two years learn the
ins and outs of this thing
and he's going to take me along on the
ride and
then i'm going to have skill set i'm
going to have to get
a ringside seat to a world-class leader
and then i'm going to have him on my
uh as a reference the rest of my life
yeah dude i'll
i'm i'm going to be real rude for a
second go make the money i'm going to be
rude for a second
okay if you're coming to work for me and
you want to move to franklin tennessee
and the reason you want to come to work
for me is because you can go fishing
i don't think i want you
well i i also like i mean it's in my
industry and it would be um
it'd be like more responsibility and it
would be more
um i would just have the freedom to do a
lot more in the company and
and you know help the company make money
you grew up in colombia
didn't you uh
yeah i've moved all over the country
doing different different things i work
for a large
contractor oh so you've already said
okay
all right i um
okay here's the only way i know to help
you answer the question because i'm just
confused about this
call yeah me too um the um
what a good way to do this is to john
was onto something there
it's not forever but do ask yourself the
question
what do you want to be doing when you're
34
10 years from today and where do you
want to be doing it
and what kind of money do you want to be
making and what kind of a career field
do you want to be in and all those kinds
of things
and once you identify that ask yourself
the question which of these
takes you there and the love of the
great outdoors
i'm sorry that's way down the freaking
list of the discussion on this
because if you make 160 versus 180 you
can buy an
airline ticket well especially for if
you're a salesman for the amount of time
you're going to be able to get out and
go fishing
what i'm telling you if you're my friend
if you're my son
i'm telling you at 24 years of age you
are starting to grind brother go make
your money go to a place where you have
a lot of influence we're going to learn
a lot
and georgia is a beautiful wonderful
place to live and as dave said man go
spend a few weeks in the great
northwest um but man get that
stuff under your belt and then you have
a lot more options when you're 34 and 44
and 54.
yeah but but which of these decisions
takes you to where you want to be 10
years from now
and that'll get you off the short term
of oh i don't want to live here ooh
ooh and this guy's a nice guy
none of that takes you where you want to
be 10 years from now
and so the the the decision-making
variables
in this are disturbing and i can't put
my finger on exactly why i'm gonna guess
if we were to sit down and
have some coffee with this person
there's a romantic interest at one of
these places
that has a or a mom and dad interest at
one of these places well that's why i
asked if he grew up in colombia sound
like he's trying to get out of there
ah gotcha get out of the south yeah i
got to get away yeah you know i'm
getting away from crazy family or
something i don't know i don't know
what's going on i can't put my finger up
but good luck with it dude
look out 10 years and ask yourself which
of these is going to take you there and
hopefully that'll help you answer the
question better than these two goofballs
did and she'll go with you trust me
yeah she'll come find you if she's worth
it or you'll go back and buy an airline
ticket or whatever however that works
i think we overthink stuff dave 24 years
old just getting ready
listen yeah you don't you know where are
you going to college so and so why
my girlfriend's going there bad plan
warning warning this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash
budget we absolutely believe in it
you ever asked the question how much
should i be saving or how do i get out
of debt faster
or how do you invest because i can't
even spell it well here's the good news
you don't have to figure out the answers
on your own
ramsey plus which contains financial
peace university
will guide you every step of the way
with the ramsey plus membership you get
all the digital teaching
that you need to really understand money
so you can be confident you're always
doing the next right
thing our world-class budgeting app
every dollar our tools our guided action
steps to help you make progress on your
money goals fast
all of this causes you to win with money
many times for the first time ever
no more debt there is cash in the bank
for emergencies and
a real plan where you have a sense of
control because you have
control ramsey plus helps you get small
consistent wins every day that lead to
big results and lifelong habits to get
started today with a free
trial text trial to 33
789 text trial two
three three seven eight nine dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five portland oregon is on
the line dave's calling hi dave how are
you
oh great dave how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
i love it hey man uh good to be on with
you uh
it's funny we just started listening to
your show recently
my wife and i up until that point we
thought hey man we got it going on and
we started listening to your show and
went
i don't know i don't know if we have it
going on
let's lay our scenario out for dave
ramsey and see what he would say and
what he would do
any differently than what we're doing
okay you know kind of
yeah so looking for some notes i suppose
okay
yeah far away what do you got i don't
know okay i'm 49 she's 46.
uh we've got high school age kids i'm a
real estate broker i work independently
self-employed she's a stay at home um
we own our home not outright that's what
we started like questioning ourselves as
we're listening to your position on real
estate mortgage you know mortgages
in general uh how much how much debt do
you have other than your home
none oh i have one we have we we own
three cars two were paid for
and mine is a lease okay all right and
so what does it take to pay that fleece
off
uh you know like 20 some odd grand worth
of least favorites probably
and what do you well give or take it'd
probably be a little less than that but
the um
well if you're gonna keep the car be
more than the lease payments but anyway
so yeah probably more like 50 grand or
something i guess yeah so what's your
household income
about 500k cool why don't you just pay
that off
yeah you know i'll tell you where i'm
all spread around and yeah
that's one of the thoughts and actually
called my account last year instead of
at least make all of my
lease payments my remaining lease
payments kind of you know tax tax
deducted for the year b said do not do
that
um so here's what i got going out right
so i've got my house um
we owe about 870 on our house
i have it on a 20-year mortgage start
off on a 30
and i know i don't want to have 30 years
of the mortgage payment so i refined it
to a 20 at two and a half percent
nice uh yeah yes that's about six grand
a month taxes and everything all in
um uh we own four rental properties
this is kind of also where we started
questioning ourselves like dave ramsey
said don't buy a property list if you
pay it in full
yeah um so of the four properties
one of them is paid in full uh and the
other
three are about 50 equity they're all
worth say give or take 200 grand and
what's owed on the other
all less than 100. okay well let's start
with let's start with this premise okay
you make a boatload of money you're very
successful congratulations
very well done what what could i do
to add to the peace
in your life financially and add to the
probability
that you end up more wealthy than if you
hadn't
talked to me and my suggestion
my suggestion to do that would be let's
take this
wonderfully large shovel you have of 500
000
a year and let's line up all of your
debts your rentals your home
and that stupid fleece car and let's
just begin to eliminate debt
because if you were making 500 000 and
all of these properties were paid for
wow what a cool place
i should think so yeah and that's going
to take a while
because you got it sounds to me like you
got a million and a half or me and two
in debt
and you make 500 and so if you put 300 a
year on it it's gonna take you four
years maybe five years to clean up
everything
but the beautiful thing is that
mathematically you can do that and still
live a
very tall cotton lifestyle or you can
roll off one of those houses
that you owe and if you got one of the
rentals you're not thrilled with and use
some of that equity to
accelerate the process but 870 on your
home making 500
man you can knock that out fast there's
no panic on it the other stuff i'd be
leaning into pretty hard and
more than anything i want you to do what
you're doing with this phone call and
that's start to get very intentional
with every one of these dollars
it's easy to get sloppy when you have
this much money coming in
it's easy to get chaotic and justify
this and justify that
because you go i make a half a million
dollars you know what you do that's
pretty stinking incredible very few
people do
and that's wonderful so you're obviously
a bright guy because stupid people
generally don't make that kind of money
so that's an observation but yeah but
and dave you taught me this about um
scale
right so i see a number like 800
000 on a mortgage a remaining mortgage
and my heart stops yeah but you gotta
lean that against half a million dollars
yeah which means nothing so you know
take that down that's 87
000 making 50. right and so when i scale
it down i remember
when i started making 30 and then i went
up to 44.
and you know what happened to me i ended
up in more debt that first year than
when i started because i stopped saying
no and you're talking about 44 000
yeah nothing compared to this but i just
thought i'd won the lottery and i quit
saying
i quit being attentive to these details
and suddenly i had owed more money than
i when i made less money but dave
honestly what i was hearing in your
voice was
just a little bit of as you started
listening to us she went
you know i think we're not being
intentional enough and so i'm going to
ask dave for some steps
so that i can be intentional i want to i
want a path here
because i kind of been wandering around
a little bit a little loosey-goosey
little margin in the
emotions because i made enough i could
be sloppy and still look good
good news is you haven't made a
bankruptcy mistake you haven't you
haven't gone
crazy you didn't call me up with uh 87
million
you know right you know 8.7 million
dollar house yeah i mean you can call me
up with any of these things so
i i i just think you're wonderful and i
think you've got a lot of potential
i would encourage you to be very
intentional step by step
and a really good idea is let's just lay
out an
interesting little simple spreadsheet on
how fast we could pay off this stuff
if we were intentional and we limited
our lifestyle just a little bit
just a little bit because two hundred
thousand out of five hundred thousand
divided into one point two million is
six years you know and
and i always want to direct people back
to the word you said dave i
i've never heard you approach somebody
like that
but what you asked what you told them is
i want to know how i can add more peace
to your life
and if i can pull some of this can i if
i can pull the other end of that fulcrum
back
right if i can pull the other
teeter-totter back provide you less
leverage and more peace yeah two words
that don't go together financial peace
right you know like you know government
efficiency
yeah yeah but there's a moment when
you're making half a million dollars and
you think
i should be sleeping better than this i
think half a million times i shouldn't
feel
like i'm doing something wrong you know
or that i shouldn't be drowning as much
right yeah yeah
that's exactly it that's exactly it and
you know uh we took a call in the last
hour
i think it might have even been the debt
free caller um
that said you know we suddenly had peace
we suddenly had a sense of control just
because we had a plan
not because we had executed the plan yet
yeah but just going from
i don't know what the crap's going on
too i know exactly where i'm going this
is going
to be hard but i can do it and this
one's gone and then you get a little
bit there's a little piece there's you
know and but there's peace in
when you could see the light at the end
of the tunnel mathematically and it's
not an oncoming train
there's some research that says the day
you make the counseling appointment for
the first time
you start feeling better oh man you
wouldn't believe the number when we
first started doing financial counseling
people would call us up and in order to
get ready for the financial counseling
meeting
they would get their crap together yes
and they would cancel
we said i talked about it oh we that's
how that's happened a lot
when you take that first crooked step
towards
a new trajectory look confused and
stumble forward but stumble
freaking forward there you go this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh i love it in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
gabriel is here to do a debt-free scream
hey gabriel how are you
hello i'm doing wonderful how are you
today dave and dr john
better than we deserve brother where you
live i live in a little township outside
of cleveland ohio oh fun
that's a bit of a haul to nashville yes
it was a beautiful drive the whole way
down
oh that's nice how much debt have you
paid off i paid off 88 000
in student loan debt how long did this
take you this took me 34 months
good for you and your range of income
during that three years approximately
yes that would be 42 000 scaling up to
58 000.
excellent what do you do for a living i
am a software engineer for a real estate
company that's also located outside of
cleveland ohio good for you well done
dude
well done so what was the 88 you said
student loan is all student loans it's
all student loans and a little bit
bigger than i wanted because i did a
major change halfway through college and
that adds an extra year so
it's a little extra debt what's your
degree in uh computer science of course
good and then you're using it and
everything yeah
so three years ago you had what feels
like an insurmountable debt
and you're making 42 000. what made you
look at that and said i can do this
um definitely looking at it and saying
you got to get started somewhere
so getting hired right off the bat and
saying well this is time you know i
racked up all this debt over the four
years my degree helped me get my job so
it's time to put it to work and
pay the debt off stop it with your
accountability and responsibility man
we just can't have this yes
so what are you 29 28 close 27
27 all right good very cool he's not
only that he's a responsible millennial
that's so annoying oh
you're messing up all of my stuff all
your stereotypes are getting screwed up
here exactly right yeah
and he actually had a plan and he
executed the plan oh
lee wow i'm so proud of you man yeah
who was your biggest cheerleader uh
biggest cheerleaders i got a couple
people to reference one of the big ones
is definitely my mother who's here with
me today
hey mom my whole family i'm down to
represent
got friends i got an uncle and aunt that
said oh you're paying off debt let's
find some homework that we can pay you
to do got another ant that helped me let
me know
job opening position so i could get an
extra job in the final year and really
knock out the debt so thanks to all of
them
wow wow so everybody got behind you and
gave you a lift
yes that's beautiful man there is
nothing cool about finally getting out
of college at 24
and getting your first job and then
saying
i'm going to be in it for 36 months with
no dates no going out no running around
i'm just going to knock this out
what kept you going every single day um
every single day definitely looking that
at some point you're not gonna own
anybody money and it just alleviates all
the pain of
finding uh money here to go do something
fun there because you're restricted by
debt and those payments that you need to
make so that liberating feeling is
definitely what
i looked forward to you kept looking at
that long game huh yeah play the long
game
it wasn't that easy off the start
because
uh the biggest thing that i found was
there's a difference between dave
ramsey's
gazelle intense and gabriel's gazelle
and hey listen gabe there's a difference
between dave's and everybody's but yes
you're right
yeah it started that first year making
42 and then you look down and you're
like all right i'll make double payments
on my student loans this is going to be
fantastic and then you get through and
you
um get to 2019 and all of a sudden
you're like i should re-budget the whole
year and see how good i did
and i paid off 14 000 that first year
and i'm like that's not bad
listen to dave ramsey while on the
treadmill and all of a sudden i'm like i
could be doing better
so i re-ran those numbers budgeted for
four things and i actually found out
ten thousand dollars i couldn't tell you
where i spent it 2018. wow
oh and like you say you do a budget you
give yourself a raise i got a ten
thousand dollar raise
tacked it out of the 14 stretched every
dollar a little bit farther
paid off um six eight jobs yeah yeah
thirty thousand the next year and then i
got those extra jobs going in the third
year of
2020 and then i paid off 44 of the
remaining debt in that final year wow
that's a curve right there baby
power the snowball kicking it you are
kicking it
well it was more than snowball his
intensity snowballed yeah that's that's
a snow plow
sacrifice well done sir very very well
done
okay so you're a professional now 88 000
paid off you're a professional get out
of debt guy
tell america how do you get out of that
um for me
what worked best i'm a numbers guy i had
spreadsheets i made my own amortization
charts so every payday when i sent it
off to pay parent minus loans or
government loans was like
all right you know i only got 24
payments left and then 23 payments left
but having that
visualization really helps i also have
my um
debt-free payment sheet here so every
time
i paid them off just there's the
refrigerator magnet
yeah baby visualization that that's what
helped me get through it being able to
see and actually say all right we're
getting closer
it's going to happen you know it's
gazelle intense when he didn't pull out
an 80
dream journal he pulled out a single
sheet of notebook paper
right he was like done yeah six folds
yeah hey you mentioned this guy's
incredible hitting the treadmill what
are some ways you kept yourself
sane and whole during this time that's a
long time to sprint
it is um definitely finding activities
that don't require a lot of money
are really good so anything that has to
do with a little bit of charity work
doing mountain biking that's free going
on nature walks
uh staying home watching movies with
friends and family it's it's being
active
and enjoying life just not with the
super lucrative end of it for a short
amount of time
yeah so what's the biggest thing you're
gonna splurge on now that you paid off
88 000. oh jeez i could spend a while
talking about it i already got it all
budgeted out and uh
things but ideally i'm saving up now i
got my emergency fund so we're saving
for a home but
after we get that home i already have
everything picked out for my home
theater setup
ah this is gonna be a home theater wow
this is gonna be the real deal it's
gonna be a massive home theater
your neighbors are not gonna be glad you
moved in and that's good man i
i already planned on sound proofing the
walls so they won't hate me that much
you're awesome oh i'm so proud of you
brother
well done very very well done well we
got a copy of rachel cruz's book for you
know yourself know your money
our latest new york times best seller
congratulations you're a hero man
you did it you took control of your life
in a in a culture where
uh the the stereotypical news feed
is that your generation is lost and
can't do anything and you proved
all of that wrong just by taking the
taking the range of the horse and riding
it well done
i'm so proud of you thank you well well
done gabriel from cleveland ohio 88
000 paid off in 34 months making 42-58
count it down brother let's hear a free
scream
three two one i'm debt free
[Music]
i love it wow that is
fun fun stuff
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five jason is with us in norfolk
hi
jason welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how you doing good man what's up
well i'm calling um for a couple of
reasons
um my wife and i are working on
purchasing or building a house and we've
been doing your program for now for a
little while
we've paid down i think nine or ten
accounts
and we are in uh baby step number two
and uh i think it's been around forty
two thousand that we've paid
bail in columns and now
the problem is this is that the land
that we're building on was heated to us
from families
specifically to be used for that kind of
thing
and we're looking to get our house and
stuff like that but
we have now the only three accounts left
are our two cars
and a trailer rv trailer that i got
stuck with
with a previous marriage um not too much
on it than what it's worth
and so we're trying to find out what to
do and where we are
and snowballing everything what do you
owe on it doing that
27 what's it worth
um well i was told by some people 19 and
i've been told 12.
okay so you need to borrow the
difference or have the difference what's
your household income
we make about 152 right now that's good
you can come up with a 10 000 difference
and get the things sold yeah
we're working on that the question is it
up for sale
is it up for sale um
not at the moment i have it at a
friend's house because our
current place we rent is an hoa and i
haven't been able to
get it here to prepare it to sell and i
don't have a truck anymore to choke
how long has it been sitting at the
friend's house
um about a year i'm calling bullcrap you
need to get your butt in the car and go
over and get that thing cleaned up and
get it up for sale man get your ten
thousand dollars scraped together good
hanging onto your old marriage brother
this thing needs to go bye-bye and then
some of these cars need to go by by and
you don't need to be building a house to
get this mess cleaned up
you stay in that rental house till that
happens time to get focused
dude you're playing you're eating around
the edges you need to bite right in the
middle of the apple here
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney my co-host today this is
the ramsey show open phone's at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five jack
is in california hi jack welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can we help um so i wanted
some
some advice on on my current situation
um i started binge watching your show
about three weeks ago and
decided okay i'm gonna because i want to
buy a house soon so i
paid off all my credit cards but the
problem i'm having right now is i have a
car that's
i spent way too much on last year and i
bought it brand new because
i drive about 100 mile round trip so i
spent 52
000 on my car um
and it's about a 836 dollar payment
um and i was thinking okay i'm just
going to go ahead and pay this off
um because the value has already
decreased to
like 38 000 when i looked it up on kelly
blue book
so what i wanted advice on was i have
about twenty thousand dollars in my
savings good
and i put my 401k on on hold just last
good because i have i had about 15
going in there i'm 25 years old i got
40k in there
which i want to use for a house um
this year i'll make between 120 and 150.
excellent okay so and you the balance on
the car is what
the balance on the car is about 47 000
because i just bought it in september of
last year gotcha so you throw 20 at it
and that leaves us with 27 and you make
100 and some change
and you pay it off in a year right yeah
so that's what my
my question was because i was thinking
of keeping like ten thousand dollars in
my savings
no okay
you're broke man 800.
yeah no it's ridiculous yeah it's
horrible
i'd be i'd be freaking out yeah
and i i realized uh you know watching
your show and then i started paying off
my credit card
and i was like you know what if i if i
want to buy a house i'm going to have a
mortgage payment and a 800 dollar car
payment
you're not doing realistic okay i'll
come i'll come to california and box
your ears you're not doing that
no you no you you're too smart to do
that let me tell you where you're
struggling
okay you've learned all of this
information and implemented all of this
in a very short period of time
your intellect went way ahead and left
your emotions behind
right you know what i'm saying like you
understood this intellectually and you
went
like ding ding ding ding ding and you
start doing it
and then you're kind of like getting a
little bit of emotional whiplash because
this has all happened in a relatively
short period of time agreed
yeah and and you know what watching your
show helps me out so much because a lot
of this stuff is
the stuff that my my parents are very
frugal um and they taught me all this
stuff
and they were freaking out when you
bought this 52
000 car yeah but they let they let me
make my mistakes
well yeah you're a grown man and that
you know stupid's not illegal
and you explained it to them in a good
way why you needed this one too
yeah 100 miles a week which means i'm
going to destroy the value faster
that was that was me justifying it in my
head yeah but i knew i heard you did
when i was doing it
yeah i heard you but you made me realize
uh how stupid it is when i started
watching your show
i think i think you're smart and i think
you're going to turn this around
it's just the re the reason you're
saying but but
i'm gonna keep the ten thousand dollars
is is not because you intellectually
don't see how this is all gonna pan out
it's because you've done it all in a
very short period of time and you went
from way over here in the land of stupid
to
rushing over into the land of the wise
and it you got a little whiplash doing
it emotionally it takes your emotions a
little time to catch up
so give yourself permission to go this
feels weird but i'm going to do it
anyway
and you feel exposed when you get down
to that one thousand dollars and i think
that's the point right yeah we want you
running
well and we want all that money throwing
at this stupid car to get rid of this
debt
but when somebody binge watches dave
they realize oh gosh i'm not
safe and they immediately want to get
safe now yeah
and so it's i get that impulse i gotta
hang on to this and let me tell you the
other thing
those of you out there that are uh you
know you've been broke for
20 years living paycheck to paycheck and
you work through this stuff and you work
your butt off and you're gonna sell
intense for three years and then you're
debt-free and you don't have any
payments
and then you start actually getting some
money and then you look up and you go
dead gum i have several hundred thousand
dollars and i have no debt
there's a there's another thing that
happens is your emotions are still back
there when you're broke yeah
and it feels weird to be able to buy a
ten thousand dollar thing
and just write a check for it and it's
not a big deal
yeah mathematically intellectually but
your emotions are like
back there when you were broke right so
you gotta heal along the way too yeah
i mean we spend more on copier paper and
coffee here
than i used to make right in this
building i mean
okay i have a thousand employees well i
looked down at that number and i said
your heart stops numbers going through
i'm like
i'm that little 28 year old guy that's
back there broke 30 years ago
i'm like crap yeah what a coffee
you know it's like oh that's a lot of
coffee so you know
the last time i bought a new car when i
was an idiot was was
a long time ago i went to we're looking
at buying my wife a
a new car and or a used car new to her
i thought when did the prices go up and
she was like 25 years ago
right but yeah it's that same they want
what for a used car
but as you move away from uh
one set of financial values
and operating in one financial reality
and you move into another one
your intellect often goes before your
emotions almost always
and then like it's like later on so i
have to
look down at the coffee bill and and go
okay
this company did bring in 350 million
dollars so we can
probably cover this coffee bill you know
so shut up you little whining boy yes
but on the other hand i look at that
number and it just there's still that it
still activates those old emotions
and so that tells me that still today my
emotions have not caught up with
the intellectual activities required to
run a 350
million dollar company and it may never
it may every time they do the company
grows so i can't keep up
that's right that's right i can't keep
the same thing with me you know sharon
and i were looking at buying something
last night and she goes i want to get
this and i'm going to spend a lot of
money and she told me how much it was
and i went
that is not a lot of money you little
goob buy it but
that nine-year-old little girl from east
is still like well that one
the one that was terrified and didn't
think we'd ever be able to fill up her
grocery basket again in the grocery
store
yeah and now can and not think about it
but she's like that's a lot of nanny
she's like a mischievous like she's
doing something wrong i'm like honey
puts two to zeroes on it and we'll call
it a lot of money that's not a lot
i think dave that is so wise that
whether it's your
marriage whether it's your kids whether
it's you're in a career
money to always just pause have some
built-in pauses
to go here's a conversation we're having
upstairs we're working on this new book
we're you know we we say here
if you're not growing you're dying and i
asked the team it just hit me like a
lightning bolt
what does growing mean to you what does
growing mean to you and they were saying
you know intellectual stimulation
and exercise plan a good morning routine
and reading and spiritual growth and all
these things
and david occurred to me in this
conversation this is just yesterday by
the way so i'm still processing it but
when you go lift weights you're actually
tearing your muscles down
it's when you rest that the growth
happens and so it's both and
right it's it's crushing it and
reflection and so it's gazelle intense
and
i'm in a new stage here you are busting
the lactic acid man yeah
i'm in a new stage in a new stage and a
new stage and there's
the pruning that causes growth yeah and
man it's always a breakdown to build up
always and when you it's when you read
that hard book or that hard class it's
at night when you sleep that's when the
neurons grow
that's when the growth happens right and
so it goes back to it's both and
maybe i should sleep more i'll always
tell you that
yes but i love this gazelle
and hey don't forget to be reflective
and realize hey you're safe now
you're safe now and now we're gonna
start working about giving and building
and it's it's just keep letting you make
sure your head and your heart stay
connected through this whole process man
yeah that that's um so jack all of that
rant to say that um
for everybody else out there listening
what you're going through is normal yeah
it's a it's a normal part of the process
for your emotions to catch up with your
intellect
take the whole 20 000 down to 1 000 work
the baby steps like you heard when you
were binging
and let's get that car paid off and get
that debt out of your life and the good
news
is you can look back when you're 54 and
go
you know one of the dumbest things i
ever did was back when i was 24. i
bought a 50
000 car when i was 24 and you can look
back
at this could you know you may have
gotten the dumbest thing out of the way
we should have gotten the dumbest thing
i was ready for check that list
the dumbest thing you're ever going to
do could already be on the list
that's a win that's a good way to think
and
at the end of the day you end up with a
50 000 paid off car that's not a bad
not a bad way to end the constellation
prize this is the ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the ever
popular podcast
by the same name dr john delony podcast
be sure and check it out
he's here to answer your questions about
your life i'm here about your money in
your life and we've got an opinion about
everything so jump in we'll help
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five lindsay starts us off
this hour
in los angeles hi lindsay how are you
i'm good dude how are you
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
so i was involved in a classroom in
february
uh praise the lord i'm okay my baby is
okay but my car was totaled
um i got a settlement for about ten
thousand
i believe it was about ten thousand
seven hundred and i tithed on it gave
to ten percent to the lord and i have
left about
9 500 and my husband and i have 12
000 about 14 000 in debt and
i'm wondering if i use that settlement
money to pay off that debt or do i save
it
to get a new car okay so
the car you were driving the car you
were driving that was totaled
was worth how much um
i believe it was worth about ten
thousand i think they gave me what it
was worth
okay so this money is for the car that's
not for any injuries or anything like
that
yes sir sorry about that oh that's okay
i'm just saying so you were driving a
ten thousand dollar car
they gave you ten thousand dollars
approximately and
now you buy a ten thousand dollar car
right what's wrong with that plan
um well um i'm trying
it's been hard finding a car because i
commute i want to get
a car that's reliable you were driving a
10 000
car yes sir
before and we were not having this
discussion about reliability
okay um okay okay i guess
sounds like you're overthinking it or
trying to try to no you're trying
as an excuse to move up in cars yeah
like you like you're gonna win something
you didn't win anything they just made
you whole if you if you break even on
this deal you
you come out really good or if you move
down in car you come out really good
so what was the car you were driving
that got killed
it was a 2012 camry okay
not a bad card 2012 camera is pretty
reliable
yeah yeah it was amazing i loved it i
bought cash for it and i was really
upset that it got um so found an amazing
2012 camry for ten thousand dollars
because that's what that one was worth
okay all right um all right is that okay
yeah i'm i'm i was really wanting
something that would get me better gas
mileage because i can use it to work
than a camera yeah my camera did
it did well it did okay um i just you
know not an f-150
i mean so okay what are you thinking
about
okay let me just settle this all right
dude
it will be a mistake please do not for
your sake
use this horrible tragedy as an excuse
to go further
up in car and set yourself back
financially
and you are rationalizing your butt off
i can hear it
so here i'll tell you um so what i was
but i was thinking my husband just set
the record straight my husband thinks
that we should pay this money to pay off
the debt
but it's cause then you would not have a
car
right exactly that's what i'm thinking
yeah so i
i want to use it for a car but i want to
finish paying off our debt
because we're really really close i want
to finish paying off our debt and then
just save like a couple
just a couple more thousand dollars to
get myself something that's got low
mileage and that will
do well like a prius lindsey think about
it this way getting in a car wreck
was not a scratch-off ticket
you did land with ten thousand dollars
in your pocket and if you were walking
to work
then maybe this is a different
conversation but you need a good
car to get you to and from and the
insurance company did what they were
supposed to do and they made you whole
and what you're trying to do is figure
out how to make be whole plus
and you can't okay i just want you to
get back to where you were just get back
to zero that's not worse not
better that's right you didn't win
anything and the insurance did what
they're supposed to do they paid you
and so go get that same car back and
then move on with your day
and don't overthink it okay now you know
if you
if you owed eighty thousand dollars on
the car fifty thousand dollars on the
car
and this paid the car off and got you
out of a mess and we can move you down
in car
we would talk about that but your car is
very reasonable
don't move up and and set yourself back
and use some of the money you should
have been using for debt
but you're also not required to move
down to a two thousand dollar car
either in this situation so if i woke up
in your shoes
i would buy a ten thousand dollar car
that got good gas mileage
and by the way there's prius on the
market with that for ten thousand
dollars
absolutely yeah and i'm not sure that's
moving up in car
well played i i also understand
you owe very little money left and
you've got a ten thousand dollar check
in your account and i get that's hard
but you can't you don't be careless i
mean no you can't but but i get it
and then you gotta go on and get a car
right if that was gonna work you would
have
had the car for sale sign in the car
when it got totaled and that's that's
that's where she's not able to make that
leap right and we think that when we
get an insurance settlement we win you
didn't man that's not what that's
supposed to be
no it's supposed to make you whole
believe me here insurance settlement and
win are never in the same sense right
right that never works that way so good
question thank you for calling yeah i
love that heart
anthony's with us anthony is in los
angeles hi anthony
welcome to the ramsey show hello
gentlemen good afternoon
um i was just calling because uh
officially i was
i got out of the marine corps for uh
i've been in there for four years
talking to the phone brother hey all we
hear is muffled man you're gonna speak
into your phone
yeah sorry about that um so i was just
calling
uh i just recently got out of the marine
corps
um i served four years 22 years old and
i'm looking to buy my first home
with the va loan um i've been approved
for 5.5
uh with zero down and i'm wondering how
much of that would be smart to actually
use
none of it none zero there's not a
sentence that's come out so far that was
smart
except for except for the part where you
served your country thank you for doing
that that's right
but the uh uh all right so let's stop
you realize the current interest rate is
more like two and some change not five
and some change
um yeah yeah they're trying to charge
you double young man did you hear me
yeah um it was about 3.25 yeah
about 275. okay quotes this morning
so on on a conventional with five
percent down what's the hurry to buy a
house you're 22 what do you do for a
living
um i do i t what do you make
uh 90k good for you it's awesome man
that's so cool
so you got some good training in the in
in the military then didn't you
oh yes are you married sir no i'm not
married
excellent okay all right my advice to
you is to wait a little while longer
and use some of your fabulous new income
to save you up a really nice juicy down
payment
and get a conventional loan the fees
and the closing costs are much lower
than on the va
and uh certainly according to your quote
the interest rates are better that's a
horrible interesting please do not buy a
zero down house in los angeles
california
with the way the market is out of
control right now yeah this is
you're gonna be over your
anytime you don't have the money to do
something and you do it it never leads
to good things
just think about it that way i hope we
stopped you get a great apartment
live your life doubt i did though but
thank you for your service this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching
to pure talk just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
hey when folks are hurting we want to
make it as easy as possible for them to
get the guidance
get the resources they need to win to
get better
and that's why we do this every day we
want to help folks
over the past year our team has been
working hard to build a brand new
website that makes it
much easier for you to find all the
great content the tools the products the
services
that ramsay has to help you improve
every aspect of your life
not just your money and guess what it
has launched
it is called ramseysolutions.com
we invite you to check it out it is well
done
i'm so proud of our tech team all the
research and process that went into it
at your one stop shop for everything
ramsay
ramseysolutions.com all your
personalities are there including
rachel ken anthony christie dr john and
of course me all in one spot
you no longer have to go on a wild goose
chase to find what you need it's all
there
easy for you to get to with a ton of
great resources
check it out it's free
ramseysolutions.com
jeff is in grand rapids hi jeff welcome
to the ramsey show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up we got a question
yeah a question for you i've been with
the same company for over 30 years
i've invested everything within my own
company i've never ventured out to
you know independent ross and i've got a
daughter that's recently graduated from
college doing exceptionally well
where she's debt-free paid the last two
years on her own i helped her out and
she got some scholarships
she's a young 22 year old with a great
job 30 000 in the bank
wow and my question is
i want to venture out to prepare for the
next stage of my life and get
an elp help or investor pro and i don't
know if we should do this together
i don't know what the best route for us
to go i know that she
i i didn't try to pressure her she's
ready to invest
so she's done everything right and i've
preached into her
which i haven't really listened to you
much i've come on to you the last few
months
from a co-worker so i'm learning myself
and i just need some guidance as to what
to do what
she should do both of us i don't know if
we should invest i'm
i'm ready to to to hook up with an elp
or smart investor pro is this something
we should do together or
i don't know you're you're independent
adults this is a father a grown lady and
her
dad right yes yeah your retirement plans
are not combined in any way with the
exception when you die you may leave
yours to her but i mean other than that
no i was just looking for an investment
yeah you can get you can both go the
same guy for investment advice that'd be
fine
so just yeah just click smart investor
pro and you know you can schedule an
appointment and go meet with a guy and
both of you meet with him and then you
can say
you what do you think you're going to
use that guy or you know do we want to
talk to another one and
you could talk that through and just
make sure you get someone with the heart
of a teacher
which you should that's we try not to
have any smart investor pros that don't
have the heart of a teacher
but um yeah it is not necessary that you
both be with the same person
it would be okay if you are but it's not
necessary and you certainly don't have
combined accounts or combined
um anything i mean you could share
information if you want to you could
talk about what we're both doing and how
we're trying to win but
but um yeah let's let's let her
uh she's done a wonderful job of
stepping out on her own and let's let
her do that
it's a common conversation day that i've
had with parents over the years
where they've just they've been needed
for their coaching and their wisdom and
their guidance and their direction and
suddenly they graduate college and
they're off doing well
and the parent goes what do i contribute
to him now
yeah and that's that shift where just
you're enough
just that relationship yeah the fact
that your dad she's gonna ask you she
trusts you you're a good guy
but now your your value is less about
what you're giving
and just the fact that you are you're my
dad right and that's a hard transition
for parents
it is it is yeah because we've gone from
doing everything for them
yeah and to doing almost nothing yeah
well
and i think we were probably doing less
than we thought but we sure gave that
advice and we sure said hey
don't forget to and then you look up and
you're like i don't know i kept the
grand babies the other day they do a lot
[Laughter]
you're doing a lot for them i'm just
saying there's a lot there's a lot of
maintenance involved
in them critters oh yes there is
theresa is in boston hey teresa welcome
to the ramsay show how can we help
hi dave and john thank you so much for
taking my call
sure um so here's our situation
um my husband and i were both 57 years
old we're
raising our granddaughter she gets about
500
a month for social security we've just
been kind of
sticking it in a you know no interest
bank account
um you have told me and others in the
past that that sort of
family money not just hers
our my main question is should i be
putting that aside for a 5-2
529 plan or should i be rounding out my
retirement
um with that extra 500 why is she
collecting that social security
um her dad has passed away and we're
raising her i'm sorry oh my gosh
yeah what in the world oh
how long ago um
six years now and um she's 11.
okay well here's the thing
no you should not be putting it in your
retirement and no you shouldn't
necessarily be putting it in the 529
it's okay if you put it in the 529 but
you are not
morally or legally obligated to do that
because the ssi that you're receiving
is not enough to cover what you spend on
this child
right she cost your household more than
that
and um and so then and you are acting as
the parent
and so you're going to do what is in the
best interest of the child
well beyond what the ssi amounts to
agreed
yes okay so what is your household
income
so it's about 140. okay and then you
have the 6000 coming in from ssi
so 146 correct correct that goes at the
top of your budget
146 and then you go through your budget
regardless of where the money came from
whether you made the money your husband
made the money with an investment comes
in whether there's ssi
it's just a pile of money and now we're
going to give every one of those dollars
an assignment towards the baby steps and
it sounds like you are out of debt and
have your emergency fund and you're on
four five and six are you
um we yes we're out of debt and haven't
um excuse me our emergency fund so you
should be putting
15 of your household income into
retirement above
in baby step four above that out of your
budget
that consists of all of your sources of
income uh you would put
above the 15 going into retirement you
would put
um uh uh some money into baby step five
towards this kid's college and that's
where you're going to load up that
uh 529 and if you have an 11 year old
you probably are
doing more than 500 a month into that
but it has nothing to do with the ssi
calculation it just has to do you have
an 11 year old you need to get caught up
saving for college
and that's probably you're probably
going to beef up baby step five and slow
down putting any extra on the mortgage
because you have a rising child heading
towards college
wide open right we also have i mean
we're 57 so
retirement's coming quick and that 500
could help
connie there is no 500.
there's no 500. okay there's 146.
okay so i need to put a little bit more
15 yeah of your income
household income into retirement
okay if you want to get real technical
about it i only put 15
of the 500 in just now okay
you want to be real technical about this
way the math happens to work out
but you need to be putting 15 of your
total household income in baby step 4
into retirement and then you need to put
all you can scrape together beyond that
into baby step five because this kid
you're late for college and and
you're you're moving forward you got 10
more years to work this kid will be out
of college and you will have built a
pretty good nest egg by then by doing
just 15
meanwhile you can work on your house
okay does that mean quit parsing this
money out
you didn't say uh i'm going to put money
aside into retirement for my husband's
income and then i'm going to put
something aside for my income no
we called it a household income there is
the whole
thing baby the whole thing and you don't
help your kid by not having retirement
paying for their college and then
needing their help
for your retirement home later on yeah
you 100 chance you're going to retire
not 100 chance they're going to college
or to some fancy special one huh this is
true
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
from the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt free stage
brent and brenda are with us hey guys
how are you hey dave
good thank you welcome welcome where do
you guys live
california we're out where abouts
sacramento oh
love sacramento awesome and originally
from new zealand i'm a kiwi
oh fun well good to have you guys how
much debt have you paid off
paid off 172 thousands uh
172 750 in about 9.2 years
good for you slow and steady and your
range of income during the 9.2
uh 130 to 195. what do you guys do for a
living brendan
i work in healthcare yeah healthcare i'm
not a nurse though
i work like a coordinator back office
type of thing
front office so i'm a salesman i sell
moldings and doors
excellent very fun very fun so 9.2 years
was this your house
yes sir i'm weird you are officially
weird people i paid for a house in
california you are
double down on weird i love it man i'm
proud of you guys
thank you we are thrilled what is this
house worth
probably about 450 and we bought it we
bought it for about 2 30.
and you own it baby yes sir i love it
so what put you on this journey 9.2
years ago
well i've been a fpu coordinator and
just uh became a
dave ramsey financial coach so we've
been leading fbus
and i think just
the power of compounding interest and
realizing how much money
you can bank in your own account you
know if you if you get ahead of the
mortgage and pay it off you can save
thousands and thousands of interest
absolutely also i'm in
sales so you know in the housing economy
it can be up and down
so it's up at the moment but one day
it's going to be down so having
having no house payment is going to be
really sweet when it goes down
yeah it's going to well i mean the whole
thing just gives you stability
yeah well done so brent and brenda the
number of
i'm gonna get in shape this year's i've
done
is a lot and i last about two and a half
weeks i work out real hard i get all the
the forms and new weights because it's
always the way it's pro how in the world
have you all kept plugging at this for
nine and a half years
we're in it together it's a team effort
and uh we both were determined we both
had like a little sign in the
refrigerator saying we're going to pay
the
house off in this amount of time and
this year
and so we've been plugging away at it
but we haven't skimped so much we've
budget everything really well
use the financial principles techniques
and also just a testimony to
the people in our class too as well
so and sometimes it seems like that date
is a far off
a little bit but once it starts getting
closer we start getting more excited
and stuff so it's like okay we're going
to pay the house off in this amount of
time
and we'll be debt-free so so when you
put the number on the refrigerator
the very first time all those years ago
how far how long did it say it was going
to take you well it was
technically october 2021 so
um we just our mortgage was about i
think
about 10 90 we put down 2 300 a month
and just
pounded it so you beat it by about six
or eight months
over the original six or eight months
yeah very few people go longer than the
original go
yeah you almost always surprise yourself
to some degree
mm-hmm yeah and you guys did you were
the real tortoise i mean just kept
plodding man yep yes
definitely that's beautiful the
beautiful tortoise
thanks to our coordinators out here the
three coordinators
who really inspired us and uh and helped
us
how many classes have you all led well
we've only led
three classes um the last one was a
virtual but
fantastic because we got to uh
coordinate with people from alaska
and minnesota just flipping awesome oh
that would be a
zoom yeah yeah the virtual coordination
is
it's a different animal but it's also
very cool yeah very cool very cool
most of our coordination coordinators
now are virtual so
good for you guys i'm so proud of you
all right now you're professionals
you have a paid for house in california
you're professional debt reducers
what's the secret how do people get out
of debt well
i think it's actually writing things
down i i teach my students hey
write down what is your 20 year goal and
put it somewhere put it in the bathroom
like we did put it on the refrigerator
and if you have a goal if you have it
written down you walk past it every day
and and it just helps keep you focused
and
and also teaching fbu you know you're
accountable to the other students
but yeah just writing it down having a
goal is important for us
yeah fabulous yeah keep it in front of
you is
on anything maybe that's the secret for
the gym thing john
[Laughter]
appreciate you brent thanks man just
kicking me while i'm
[Laughter]
that's kind of a little deterrent so but
you got to keep plugging away and be
creative
i don't know that sounds like an excuse
you should probably write that down and
put it on the fridge
so hey who's who is beside your
classmates who is your biggest
cheerleaders
well i i gotta tell you uh we're pretty
self-motivated
but um yeah just self-motivated i
i'm on the scale of personality you'll
appreciate that uh
john is i'm probably like at 11 as far
as discipline
so i had to be careful to work with
brenda you know
not just save save save save but she can
spend a little money on this a little
bit of
money on that okay
and she works in healthcare brent so
they will never find your body brothers
like you john
we have things we can do with you
[Laughter]
you guys are fun that's all this is so
great i'm so proud of you
thank you how old are you oh uh 59.
59. yeah okay so for women don't ever
ask
them
it's too late because i don't care i
promise i won't say she's 59.
so i'm older than both of you so no
whining okay so
yeah but you're sitting here with a paid
for house
did you ever think you'd get there we
did but i
i want to share i remember at 4 35 a.m i
was in bed
i got my um online payment paid the last
payment of 15 000
i remember your statement about how it
feels so different
got up out of bed and i walked across
the room and it felt like i was walking
on air and i remember that statement you
made
it it was so amazing and i i told all
the class i said hey remember those
positive moments
paying that small debt off you know
remember and embrace that because the
positive
motivation is more important than the
negative don't do this or don't do that
so that's true
yeah that's true there's a lightness
that is very real oh
tangible fantasy that people that have
never been there don't have
yeah i'm so proud for you guys thank you
very much what a testimony to
younger folks who are looking at a pile
of student loans and say it's going to
take me three years
and you guys have set a marker out there
that says yep
it will and it's going to be worth it
you're just going to get up and do it
every day and do it every day and do it
every day you're going to find somebody
do it with you
and you're going to keep doing it and
then you're going to have that moment
where you float across your bedroom and
it's going to all be worth it
it was wonderful thank you thank you for
the inspiration you guys wow
we're so proud of you you're our
inspiration you're heroes well done
very well done all right here it is 173
000 paid off in 9.2 years
by the way that's about seven months
early making
130 to 195 house and everything
these guys have a paid for california
house
shut up count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it changes the whole equation for the
next decade
everything everything's changed so
imagine in a year
the the real estate market is is
settling and his boss calls him in and
says hey we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to to downshift our
sales goals for doors and he'll go
all right and all right
have a good week man hope i hope you're
good
hope you're doing okay yeah yeah if you
need a hug holler at me i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be
hanging out with brenda i'm going to be
going on the buy that free back porch
yeah because we don't uh have a house
payment have a good one brother
so cool guys this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
our scripture of the day zechariah 4 10
do not despise these small beginnings
for the lord rejoices to see the work
begin francis of assisi said
start by doing what's necessary then do
what's possible and suddenly you are
doing the
impossible for the lord rejoices to see
the work begin
sometimes you cannot see the end when
you start
but you need to start anyway that's what
we're saying just
start just start
you know how you become a writer you're
right you start writing
i don't know what to do an exercise
program just start doing it
anyway just start our question of the
day comes from blinds.com they have a
100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they will remake your window blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best
deal all right today's question comes
from ginger in california
she writes my husband refuses to deposit
his whole check in our joint account and
hides money in a separate account
he deposits only enough to cover our
expenses
then turns around and withdraws large
amounts later
he's a good father holy crap don't want
to ruin my kid's life
if we divorce that's it so
number one he's not a good father number
two
he's ruining your kids lives not you
being forced to do something about this
so there's not really a question here
dave this is more of a statement
yeah your husband is a twerp
he is not husband material he is not
father material
he is a self-centered little child
yes and he's yeah
he's doing just enough to keep his kids
fed and you
fed but he's a manipulative power hungry
idiot and then he doesn't even care
about y'all being fed later on
because he'll go get the money back yeah
so
uh what does she do from here um sits
with a counselor
absolutely and then she's the fact that
she said i don't want to ruin my kids
lives if we divorce tells me two things
number one she's thought about it or
number two the people in her life have
said you're this is over
and so she has built this up as i'm not
going there
and so i have met with people who have
said i won't do that
and to which you say okay then this is
the
bed you're choosing to be in you're
gonna have to make the best of what you
got inside of here
i'm going to tell her this type of
manipulation
usually comes with violence and or
volume and or other types of neglect and
manipulation beyond just the money this
is a symptom
right and she's got to sit with a
counselor and begin to create a a
or what plan because this is a mess yeah
and it's the to give you the strength
um the assurance that you're not crazy
correct
or wrong correct and the words
the narrative on how to calmly
lay down what will eventually become an
ultimatum right
or what yeah yeah and you're going to
say you're either going
to uh provide for this family by putting
your
whole check in the thing and we're all
going to work together
or we're going to talk about how we're
ending this marriage
because i'm not going to live like this
anymore and these kids are not going to
be raised with you as a model for what a
husband and a father and a provider
looks like yeah because yeah you're
damaging your children
by allowing them to think he's a good
father yes you're
throwing gasoline on a legacy forest
fire yeah you're
there because they're going to duplicate
what he does times 10
yeah right yeah and to the extent he's
yelling at you then they're going to
yell and hit
yeah and to the to the extent that a
the mother of your children is simply an
annoyance and in the way of whatever
thing you need to buy whatever event you
need to attend
that's how they're going to treat
romantic partners for the rest of their
life
yeah and you're just you're painting a
model here's what that looks like yeah
my life is more important than all of
y'all's combined
my wants and toys and fun and stuff yeah
the opposite of this is we often tell
people what is the best thing you can do
for your children
love their mother well that's it when
somebody says that's the exact
opposite of this whole thing how do i
help my kid with uh screw my kids up
drinks mistreat their mother that's
exactly right hey my kids got anxiety
what i do fix your marriage
hey my kids are struggling with xyz fix
your marriage
have a great marriage start there and
then we'll start talking about the other
stuff
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry ginger
i'm sorry it's a horrible thing it's not
even a question here it's a horrible
thing you're in but the uh
if um you know what we're seeing
you know with what you the information
you gave us uh
was not throwing your husband under the
bus if it was truthful
and it is accurate and um then you are
sitting in a mess and you need to do
something about it that's what we're
saying yeah and you probably are gonna
need some help
to do something about it it's very few
people can navigate these things
by themselves you need someone to give
you language to it and someone to say
look what you're feeling in your heart
that this is wrong and you're being
mistreated
is correct it's accurate it's accurate
because you start to feel like you're
the problem
and you're not the problem it's almost a
domestic abuse thing and here look at
what she says i don't want to be the one
who ruins my kids lives yeah
by taking care of me and my children you
know what he has said that to her
absolutely if you leave me you'll
destroy these kids
if you don't quit yelling at me about
the money you're gonna you're gonna mess
these kids up
and she says oh my gosh i'm so sorry i'm
so sorry yeah
it's got the same tone of a domestic
violence that's why you said violence
you know
ryan is there ryan's in louisville
kentucky hey ryan how are you
hey gentlemen thank you so much for
taking my call i truly appreciate it
sure how can we help well um
first off i just wanted to say thanks to
your guys
program uh my wife and i we paid off 160
thousand dollars worth of debt
debt-free number 2018.
so yeah that was awesome and um
i guess now we're sitting at uh what
would be baby step
six but we're are on active duty
military and we rent everywhere we go
good and and so i want to be saving so
that when i do retire
um you know we can pay cash for a house
so
one can i save above the 15 and two if i
can
where sh where should you know what type
of account should i be putting that into
yeah your baby step six just goes in a
separate mutual fund and you nickname
that the house fund
and you pretend like you're paying off a
200 000 house and you try to get 200 000
in there okay
okay because um so one of the things
that i'm looking at is i'll get promoted
uh later on this year so i'm gonna get a
little over a thousand dollar uh pay
bump you know per month and so
i just don't know how much of that i
guess should i be well you should
know out of your budget you're on baby
steps four five and six you should be
putting 15
of your income whatever your income is
into retirement
maybe step four five is kids college do
you have kids going to college
um they're all they're all taken care of
gi bill got it gi bill and then uh
and and then some are just in in the
military themselves oh okay
wonderful okay so that check that box
right
uh and so then you say all right
everything above 15
goes towards paying off the house early
only we don't have a house
so we are building a payout pay cash for
the house
fund so you basically which is the exact
same math
yeah so you throw everything in that
other mutual fund in baby step six
above 15 go of your household income
going into retirement so
in other words if you've got a raise of
a hundred and of a thousand dollars
you're going to raise your
retirement by 150 and that gives you
another 850 to throw towards this get
out of debt house fund
okay and i just want you to pile up cash
like
fast and furious like you were trying to
pay off a house
exactly and the average person pays off
their home in seven to eight years doing
our plan
and so seven to eight years from now i
want you to have enough in there to pay
cash for a house
okay be the same same exact math it's
just you're getting the benefit of the
money instead of the mortgage company
okay yeah it'll work for you instead of
paying that interest out that's
excellent man
yeah very well done sir and again thank
you for serving your country
yeah we really really really appreciate
that and um
yeah when you move around every two
years because they move you
and most of the housing is in a military
community where it's tough to sell a
house
you can get really stuck if you start
buying properties everywhere you go
so we tell folks if you're moving every
two years for any reason but
particularly in the military
don't buy just rent so he was following
that advice but this gave him a leg up
on the
how to offset the situation there
nothing cool to get out of the military
and writing a check for your home right
that would be pretty neat
that would be pretty neat that puts us
hour of the day ramsey showing the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts